[MUSIC THE GRASS ROOTS, "LET'S  LIVE FOR TODAY]
ROBERT GRILL: (SINGING) When I think of all the worries
people seem to find, and how they're
in a hurry to complicate their minds by chasing after money,
and dreams that can't come true, I'm glad that we are different.
We've better things to do.
May others plan their future, I'm busy loving you.
1, 2, 3, 4.
Sha-la-la-la-la-la, live for today.
Hey, hey, hey.
Sha-la-la-la-la-la, live for today,
and don't worry about tomorrow, hey.
Sha-la-la-la-la-la, live for today.
Live for today.
I got to have you now, please.
Please.
Some loving.
Baby, give me some love.
Give me some love.
Got to prepare for your loving.
Give me some loving.
I need all your loving.
Give me some love, now.
La-la-la-la-la.
Sha-la-la-la-la-la, live for today, hey, hey, hey.
Sha-la-la-la-la-la, live for today,
and don't worry about tomorrow, hey.